who is this oh my god  fellas john crispo from dallas how's  everybody doing today ah john crystal  from dallas texas  hi megan oh hello all right who do we  have here hi charlie my name is john how  are you guys this is nuts hi guys john  how are you where are you calling from  john i think you're our second john  i'm calling from boca raton florida but  i live in west palm beach  yeah all right hello yo what's going on  yo  you know we're just sitting here doing  some trivia what's going on with you and  what's your name my name is john man  another john so many john's today are  you [ __ ] with us  [ __ ] with us right now john what john  is next megan  what's the next john through  just doing all jobs  thanks for calling the always sunny  podcast you're on with rob charlie and  glenn